what's going on everyone in today's
video i'm going to show you how to
charge exorbitant prices
for your goods and services so not that
long ago my wife and i were at a charity
event for after-school all-stars at
arnold schwarzenegger's house
and i saw some of the most beautiful
displays of understanding market
economics
um that i've ever seen and so at the end
of that night i had
my hand raised and i donated a million
dollars alone
that evening based on the way that they
had manipulated the event
and so to rewind this story for you
briefly
um right as i was coming into the event
right as people were meeting each other
they wanted me to
introduce me to some of the other board
members of the charities the ceo of the
charity ben was talking to
one of the other gentlemen there who's a
big donor and he said ah what uh what he
did and what he what his recommendation
was was brilliant and i was so afraid to
do it but i'm so glad we did
and i was like well what did he say to
do he said well last year we sold the
tickets for ten thousand dollars uh
ahead just to attend the event and play
poker he said but this year it was 25
000 and we actually sold more people and
i was like that's crazy
and the gentleman i found out later had
made all of his his fortune in the ultra
high-end
jewelry business and so that is a
business of purely
understanding the demand curve supply
and demand and how to raise prices
and so he said something to me and he
said it's so smugly and so like content
with himself in this moment that i just
it just like etched into my brain he
said
you always have to remember when demand
increases he said you cut supply
and he said it just like he said you cut
supply and what that does is it jacks
prices through the roof because now you
have more people who wanted it than
before
and there are fewer items for sale and
so by doing that
you get these massively inflated prices
which plenty of us probably saw during
the
the whole pandemic and things like that
that happened on some goods
that were there all of a sudden demand
increased
right and so as extension and supply
went down and then that is what jacks up
prices
and the thing is is you can harness that
in your own business
all right so if you've ever looked at
chanel for example if you if you want to
buy a chanel bag
and these are the best people to look at
the people who've been doing this for
hundreds of years
you know at least 100 years like you
know i think don't correct around that
but
long time right louis vuitton they have
figured out they have hacked how to
generate and stimulate
demand all right so in a channel store
for example they have
one to two bags that are available
corporate doesn't let the stores know
how many and of what bags they're going
to receive it's a complete mystery
complete surprise
and they don't tell them when they're
going to stop producing stuff and they
do it all the time
and so what happens is they create this
experience where when you walk in the
door there's
absolute scarcity there because every
bag is limited edition there's only one
of a kind there might that might be the
only bag you ever see
you can't even buy these things online
and they do that by design
so they can stimulate higher prices and
so just as a
as a quick one on this um i don't know
if you've ever really wanted to buy
something
and you uh you know right as they were
about to tell you the price on the thing
you got kind of scared just like
you know you're exposed because you're
like i really want this thing right
and all of a sudden they tell you the
price and you're like thank god i would
have paid so much more than that
that is a missed opportunity because you
would have paid so much more and as the
business owner you need to know how to
stimulate that
and so i'll tell you one final example
and then i'll get into this price curve
behind me if i were to sell um
a a day of my time for five people right
i could probably say tomorrow hey it's
twenty thousand dollars
for a day there's five of you in the
room it'll be intimate
click here to buy right sure but
what i'm missing is the number one and
number two people of those five
might have been willing to pay two
hundred thousand dollars for that day
and so the thing is is as you as you cut
cut units so this is supply this is
demand this is microeconomics 101.
as you cut supply right as supply goes
down
then what happens is you can look all
the way on this demand curve right
supply goes down you can raise the price
here
what ends up happening most times is
that people will cut their supply but
then they will keep their price
uh at a lower price right it's like
they'll cut the supply to here but
they'll
they'll price here rather than pricing
all the way here
and the thing is is there's so much
extra juice in the squeeze that's
available for you
if you just know this and so my first
recommendation for you is
if you can create a limited or very
scarce
service or service level or product
that you can release i guarantee you
that you will make more money
this is the reason and one of the things
that isn't taught about this
microeconomics demand curve is that
they assume a static condition meaning
perfect marketplace all people have
perfect information
and as you shift the price you know that
you you
try and find the sweet spot but what
they don't think take into account is
that this demand curve can shift
based on marketing so if you think about
marketing isn't in a general perspective
marketing
is artificially stimulating demand
you're purposely letting more people
know about what you do so that you can
generate demand
inwards so you can shift your way this
way on this on this graph
right i'm sorry this one described
excuse me and so
what we can do here is that if we have
stimulated demand
demand goes this way right boom
it goes all the way down to here which
means that our prices
we actually can go even further along
this curve to increase the price
and here's one of the magic things about
when you control
supply if i were to sell three people
that hundred thousand dollar day for
example
i made a more money than i did selling
five people a 20k a day
but not only that it's easier for me to
fulfill
for three people so i create less
operational drag
i have way more profit right and i
create an error of premium and i can
also
delive over deliver to those clients
even more than i could before
all right and so if you have a
fundamental understanding of how this
works
the supply demand curve then you can
work in your favor and one of the
biggest mistakes that i see
with most entrepreneurs is that they
spend too much time trying to supply
and not enough time trying to generate
demand demand
is the power that's coming towards you
stimulate is you satisfying and so you
want to think about it like a seductive
dance
right where you someone someone has this
desire
right but you want to delay you don't
want to satisfy me you want to delay you
want to delay
right now there is a snapping point
where someone eventually feels rejected
but it is far
far far longer and further away than
most people think right
and so what you can do is you you tease
things you
you you flirt with them you whisper
things that are coming out you drop
these little hints drop these little
hints
right you create a waiting list right if
you had a service and you said hey
to work with me i'm all the way over
here because i can only take five
clients period
period and you cap it and you cap it
right you have five clients period well
i can i can uh i can set you up with a
waiting list and i'll let you know when
we have more slots
you will generate more demand because
also the allure around what you do
he must be good or she must be good
because they have a waiting list
because they they are no longer at
capacity and so one of the interesting
things about being at full capacity is
it's completely
up to you what full capacity means you
can say today that you are full
think about that you could say oh we're
completely capped out
you could cut off your supply to zero
right and so as soon as you cut your
supply to zero
your price shoots that way right and so
you cut your supply to zero saying i
don't take anyone
and then what happens is this pressure
builds and it looks it's like a pot
right
and then you you want to periodically
let off the steam you don't want to
be letting off the seam all the time
because the pressure never builds
and that pressure is your pricing power
and so
to wrap this all up for you the reason
it was such a
such a tremendous experience for me to
see this happen in the real world is i
saw them go from ten thousand dollars to
ticket to twenty five thousand
a second and i saw them sell more right
and so
by understanding this when you have a
limited edition t-shirt and you drop it
you will actually sell more units
not because this curve is wrong but
because the way you marketed it by
creating scarcity shifted the demand
curve in your favor people who might
other not otherwise buy or say i'll buy
later
now feel forced to buy and by extension
we can jack our prices and actually end
up selling
more units overall and so to wrap this
up for you
one if you can create an ultra high very
very very scarce very very small supply
type service or good or product i
guarantee you'll sell for more money
you'll get more people to buy it and i
think that if you just do that in your
business in some way
you will see this power harness to your
advantage and you'll see the pricing and
profit around these things and you'll
never want to go back
so hope you enjoyed this click subscribe
and i'll see in the next video